λοιπόν κι που κίνταιν ημέρν εξεκινήσαμε μια καθημερινή αυτή στη αρχιίναι πίεζμένα άμουμε κόμα μαζί
πίεση α κατεβούμε μαζί με κόμμα ια σκαετέχω α τν το πράμα ξαθνικά βρεθήκα νο
αρφόσουμ ρίκοπο ψύεος δήμαρχος υπα ένα ρφόσμου α το αφήσομια τελευταία ευκαιρία έφθασε εγότο θώ
και τραβησα πίσω και αλήθεια είναι και καισε και το στάδιο αι φιδίας έκαε τα
διαγουλεύσεις του και ποί είαι πλησάσα των και τότε η περδί ο περδίκης και σο
κρίβω ότι την απόφαση για τον περδίκη πιάσαμε την πά στην παραλία στον πρώτανών εξωπωσπίδι
ου ότι φθαβεσμο πεδίκη λοιπόν και ότε ένω ποα μέσω σο το πολέγω μιλούμε για
ένα πολλά χαρισματικό παιδί μιλούμε δηλαδή των το παιδί με τώρα τα πράγματα που κάννε
του εντι στιγμή αν εξερέσουμε κάποια λάθι πίχει του τον ποργαμον τουρκοκύπριον το οποο έχει
να κάνει με ημημάθειαν των το πράγμα δηλαδή εγώ και διάφωνο στην προσεγκήση ότι να
πρέπει να ταύρουμε μπως τορκοπάρουσ σίγουρα και τούτ με τις σωστή πλευραν της ιστορία διότε
που γίνουνται ημέρα και οπιστεύκις το έκαθισαθιβασαχή καις πεντακόες θελίδες για το κύπριακό και εκόα
κα ακόμαλαλός ότι με μημαθείς μέθα τα ούλα πόα που γίνεικε που το χ κι
οταό βδομετα αυτό έχρι σήμερα τουάχι στο άπννα μηλόκα που αξίρομετα πράγμα κα όταν το
πρά πουκαμετά λάθος αλλά να δείσω ότι αλλά να μηνο λιτόν και πυρναποε γφτάσουμ το
σήμερα και ότι καμα έπιασα των που το βουνόν επήνα το μέ το γραφεί όμως
την αρμενας έβανα των καιαμένα το γά του το γραφείο μμε ένακαμ να δουκές εγώ
ήταν οτο φιδία στον πέπτον όνο φοφωνα ντεράτ διαμέρεισμμίνεις και μέσα μούκτη τάξει έαμ τα
ώκα πάνω που κάτω μεινής κανω δεν πια το λουκάνικ ι αρφή του μάλο ένας
πάντω και που κίνταην ημέρα κάθε ημέρα κάνονα με πω δηλασίες γυμναστικής βίτιο πράματα αιτα
λοιπά και οργανών να με την προκλογική το τάξει των το πράείχεείχε μέρα απου είμα
το δώδεκα ώρες λάιπου τ δανιαγιαγόεκαα στογίο κιο και ρκιόιο για στο τικό στακαι